so we're going to get started good
afternoon everybody
I am Shawn law I worked here at TD
Ameritrade I'm a loan sort of a loan I
have markers here with today a vengeance
out at Syfy so he's having a lot of fun
out there so a lot of the typical
preamble as always for this project you
have to occur we like to acknowledge
numb focus as well as TD Ameritrade and
spark and Midas especially my again my
sister for supplying the food it's
sponsoring the food and for those who
are new a couple of emerges a good
public couple of important points
emergency exits in case of anything that
happens or is it active right up here
and it affected right out the front
doors that you came in through we're
always soliciting for speakers so we
would love to get local speakers do if
you work at a company work with the
universities come tell us your native
stories and because we're data failures
because we all know that we aren't all
experts in creating success right and
it's important that at the community we
kind of own up to those to those
failures too and share those stories
Marcus is in charge of workshops that
we're planning up in the upcoming month
so please reach out to market standing
over there and the Hat you have ideas of
a hands-on workshops that you might want
in the future and also as always we're
always soliciting feedbacks think that
we're doing well and more importantly
things that we can improve upon that
would be great
always visit us our github page at high
data Ann Arbor you can only find the
talks there as well as other information
and also you can tweet us or send us an
email I did an arbor at gmail.com and
also unless you have quick questions
during the talk please hold your
questions to the end and remember that
we're in a borrowed TD Ameritrade space
so please clean up after yourselves
especially got food and a place to know
what not consistent with our previous
talks I like to read our PI data go to
conduct or split that are new so PI data
is dedicated to providing a harassment
free meeting experience for everyone
regardless of gender
sexual orientation gender identity and
expression disability physical
appearance by size race or religion we
do not tolerate harassment of meeting
participants in any form all
communication should be appropriate for
professional audience including people
of many different backgrounds sexual
language and imagery is not appropriate
for any of our meet of events be kind to
others do not insult a put-down other
attendees behave professionally
and remember that harassment and sexist
racist exclusionary jokes are not
appropriate for high data attendees
follow these rules they be asked to
leave the meetup at the sole discretion
of the meetup organizers and thank you
for helping helping to make this a
welcoming and friendly event for
everybody okay
and with that I always like to as you
know do an icebreaker just like when you
leave here you would have at least met
somebody
so today's icebreaker is turn to
somebody either to your left or to your
right and either tell them a data
science or Daniel related conference
that you've been to or a conference that
you would like to go to in the near
future introduce ourselves
pick a friend real quick
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
hey we're back thank you so as always we
like to talk quickly about survey a
maybe interesting thing in data science
this this month actually this has been
around so I came across something called
PI check i/o so if you're somebody who
is looking to improve your Python skills
you can go there and you'll see will be
presented with problems python-based
problems or even though I guess it may
support a JavaScript as well so if
you're kind of trying to improve your
your field check that out or even if
you're an interviewer you're looking for
good solid questions to ask you know
skills questions that's also a great
place to yeah I think I'm one with
people to introduce this to you there's
two sides of this website not only does
it do the JavaScript and Python side of
things and it's like practical problems
like practical like interview questions
you might say the whiteboard question
like return all the redundant elements
out of a list like that sort of stuff
those kind of questions but they
increase in complexity but furthermore
they have another side it's called a
like more empires or something like that
and it's actually think of like clash of
clans that you can actually click on the
Kurds and optimize them with Python code
or JavaScript code and it's just a fun
way to implement your coding different
way and one other thing we've been doing
this for a few months now so the folks
at O'Reilly have been kind enough to
offer free ebooks so if you tweet at us
at
paji to Ann Arbor you can grab one of
these three ebooks and the last but not
least is advertising for next month
hydrated meet up so we have Sebastian
Raska who is a graduate student who is
graduating soon at MSU but here's also a
great author that wrote the book called
up - Python machine learning and next
website you can come in and talk to
about an introduction to deep learning
with tensorflow
so definitely come out and catch that
one Sebastian arguably is one of the
greatest educators of machine learning
in our generation oh this is my opinion
me because I went to MSU but he'll be on
Thursday August 24th and Sebastian is
generally a great great person to have
around so what's that
let you plug in sure and I'll introduce
our speaker today this is Gus Gordon
from quanto Pia so Gus is a data
engineer at canto pian which he'll tell
you a little bit more about but he did
his undergrad in physics and economics
at Bucknell University and he was
mentioning that I think is C oo was a
Michigan grad yes exactly and uh yeah
let's welcome go thanks a lot Sean it's
great to be here it's really nice out
here so thanks everyone for coming
so today I'm going to be talking about
how to develop a stock trading algorithm
using only open source Python tools so
just quick disclaimer I have to show I'm
sorry
read it ok that's good enough so if you
want to develop your own algorithmic
stock trading strategy you have like
three main ways I think so the first way
is to use a platform like pronto again
so this is definitely the easiest and
fastest way so it's just a quick shout
out to my company it's basically website
where you can go on and develop your own
trading algorithms so right now we
support
our US stocks and futures and if your
strategy is good enough we'll find you
and contact you and maybe invest some
real money in that strategy and give you
a share of the profits so that's
probably the easiest and fastest way but
there are certain limitations of that
for example you're using someone else's
platform you have less flexibility
inherently when you do that so another
way is to build your own tools like your
own your own way to test your trading
strategies and that's called back
testing this is not great because it's
really time consuming to actually build
tools that are you know very good and
usable there's a million different
things there's many different edge cases
that you run into if you build your own
tools although it is doable and people
do do it another certain not the last
way the PLAs main ways to use
pre-existing open source tools so at
point-o peein we've open sourced a lot
of our core products we have our back
tester which allows you to test your
your stock trading strategies and then
we have different analyses packages and
this is what I'll be talking about today
so how to use open source tools in this
case quant opions open source tools to
build your own trading strategy you can
just do this on your computer it's
you're not dependent on another platform
or anything like that right so the first
thing when developing a trading strategy
is to have some sort of hypothesis or
idea so like for example that idea could
be like I think stocks
price is going to go up when a lot of
people tweet about it or I think stocks
exhibit mean reversion meaning the price
will always return or not always but
will often return to like a previous
value something like that so yeah you
start with an investment hypothesis
so I was trying to think about what see
I was trying to think about what like a
good idea for this talk would be I guess
it's a little small but the talk on the
left here is called rainmakers why bad
weather it means good productivity and
so this caper basically says that when
it's raining outside people are more
productive working inside and
specifically they're more productive at
like menial tasks like data entry stuff
like that and when it's sunny outside
they're like more creative and then
another paper sort of in the same vein
but this time involving the stock market
is called good day sunshine stock
returns in the weather and it basically
concludes that like when it's sunny
stock traders are sort of see more like
glass half-full they they predict that
stocks will go up and so that means that
stocks will go up so basically like if
it's sunny on Wall Street the market
will have tend to have a good day so I
took these two papers so the algorithm
will we're building today we'll take
rainfall at a given company's
headquarters as a signal so like for
example Apple is in Cupertino so like
like what will take if it rained in
Cupertino as our signal for determining
whether the the stock price will go up
or down so then more firmly our
hypothesis is that recent rainfall at a
company's headquarters as an effect on
the company's stock price okay so in
order to actually do this we need a few
things so first we need to gather all
the data so what we need is company
tickers we need rainfall data and
pricing data so this will be kind of
like the first half of the present age
and then once we do that we can
investigate this rainfall signal with
alpha lens which is a so all these are
quanto pian open source packages so well
investigated with apple and then we'll
create an algorithm with zip line and
then we'll analyze the resulting back
test with pipe folio okay so the first
thing is gathering required data so we
need a universe of stocks to look at so
we can't we need like we need like a set
of ticker symbols right so a good set of
ticker symbols to start off with is S&P
500 which is just 500 US equities so
it's actually really tricky to get the
historical S&P 500 it's trickier than I
thought it would be like the S&P 500
website only has the current S&P 500 so
you have to like look in other places
for the historical one so I found this
repo on github that has like it
automatically updates its list of the
S&P 500 so I just kind of like pull in
these VCS fees that are historical and
then I can read in the S&P 500 for that
year and I'm just using yearly S&P 500
but you could use like quarterly or
whatever - if you wanted a higher
resolution and we're using the S&P 500
at the start of the year to avoid
survivorship bias so if we just said the
the S&P 500 for 2015 was the S&P 500 at
the end of 2015 then we would tend to
pick stocks that survived 2015 and we're
still in that 5500 throughout 2015 so
that's called survivorship bias question
are you using the index for the 500
figures yes the 500 tickers in this case
yeah because we just want like a list of
500 names that our strategy will use
it's just my stuff like a finite list
okay so now we have the S&P 500
so for each company in the S&P 500 for
our strategy we need the address of the
company's headquarters and then once we
have the address we can get the rainfall
at that address so this is like another
tricky thing so there's just like little
function here I won't go too deep into
it but basically it tries to get a
company location from the Securities and
Exchange Commission you can basically
just like enter a ticker symbol into the
website and it will give you the address
and if that fails then we try to grab it
from Bloomberg and so this function just
returns like an address or maybe a zip
code in this case yeah I think it just
returns a zip code so now that we have
this zip code that just gets plugged
into geo PI which is a really nice
package I found I don't know if they
even heard of it but you can just like
give it an address and it will look up
the address for you and give you a set
of of geographic coordinates like a lot
of - longitude and it's really nice if
so then basically we go through each of
the the 500 symbols for each year and we
store a mapping from our symbol to
latitude and longitude and we just store
it in a panda's data frame here and you
can see it right here so our index is
the symbol on the left and the latitude
and longitude on the right so just
glancing at this it seems correct
because the latitude is positive and the
longitude is negative which kind of
means we're like in the northwest
quadrant of the world which is where the
United States is so it makes sense that
US socks would have headquarters with
those a lot of student longitudes if
that makes sense okay so now that we
have
that we have the company locations we
also need US weather stations so weather
data is something else that's tricky to
find
but the NOAA National Oceanic and
Atmospheric Administration has this data
on their website in like a pretty decent
format so they have a bunch of weather
stations around the world or sorry
around the US and they store their
allotted they also saw the latitude and
longitude so there's like 3,000 stations
or something around the u.s. so this
weather stations data frame here is just
a list of weather stations and their
latitudes and longitudes so now we have
company locations and weather station
locations and this is a map of the sort
of blue dots our weather stations and
the red x's are sp500 headquarters so
you can see the the weather stations are
kind of scattered around the US and so
are the headquarters so now for each of
these headquarters we want to find
basically like the closest weather
station with data so then we can map the
headquarters to a weather station and
get the data from that station okay
right so this this function just Maps
our our headquarters to the weather
station and then gets the weather at
that station so it's a little this is a
little tricky here all this this all
this presentation will be online
afterwards if you want to dive into the
code more but just giving through it
yeah we just get the latitude and
longitude for the company locations find
the closest station and then this
function here that I'm not showing get
station participer to
precipitation gets the rainfall data
from that closest weather station and
then stores everything in a in a data
frame and if the weather station for
whatever reason has a bunch of like
missing values then we just go to like
the next closest station if that makes
sense
yep so then all that gets stored in the
data frame called symbol HQ
precipitation yeah so there are daily
figures right is a forecast for the tab
it's on its past real data like actual
rainfall data so like for example
whatever the ap ticker symbol is it
rained there on January 2nd in this the
units here are like our tenths of
millimeters of rain so you can see like
at Apple AAPL
it didn't rain at all but like some
other some other symbols it did rain a
little bit this is just like the first
five rows of that uh of that data frame
okay so now we have all the data all the
rainfall data we need so the last thing
we need is pricing data pricing data is
pretty easy to get so Yahoo and google
both provide daily daily pricing data so
they both provide like okay what is the
clothes of Google oh sorry let me think
of a better example so like what is the
clothes of Apple on like any given day
and they just have daily data so this
function just goes through our sp500
symbols and it grabs the closes it tries
to grab the closest from Yahoo and if
that fails and it gets it from Google
and then yeah and then that all gets
sorted in a data frame called pricing
zoom out here so here's the the pricing
data frame so you can see it just it
just stock prices daily for every symbol
here
where the columns are just the ticker
symbol and so this is all of our pricing
data so this is pricing data from when
we started getting that the S&P 500
which was 2015 to present so it's like
two and a half years of data but one
thing I would recommend is to create
like a testing set for pricing so to
like withhold some data so that you have
some data that you haven't looked at
that you can that you can use later in
the process to see if how your algorithm
would do after you've actually made the
algorithm on data it hasn't seen yet so
this is a simple way to just like
withhold data so right here I just make
a another data frame called pricing
underscore test which is just this
except we're not including 2017 so this
is like seven months or of data or so ah
I think yeah so Yahoo does but Google I
think just adjusts for splits not
dividends if I'm correct yeah okay yeah
so Yahoo is a little bit better in my
experience okay so now that we have like
all the data we needed we can generate
our training signal so for our trading
signal I thought that like using a three
month rolling mean of daily rainfall
would be good because like earnings get
released quarterly which is like every
three months so maybe maybe that makes
sense
obviously like you could experiment with
this so I'm just taking the rolling
three-month mean of the rainfall at each
headquarters and then I and then
normalize that range ball for each
headquarters so that our maximum value
for so that our maximum value of
rainfall is like 1.0 and then our
minimum is zero so then every value here
should be between zero and one besides
things that are missing right so you can
see like some stocks have more rainfall
some have less
that just means there's missing data so
like maybe maybe the pricing data or
sorry maybe the the weather station like
didn't have precipitation data on that
in that period or something
is it only rainfall hours at
precipitation so it includes snow um I
think this is just rainfall though but
that's a good point
I assume or clear okay so now I'm going
to break out of this
so this is all in a in a Jupiter
notebook by the way which is like which
is like a really convenient way to do
things because you can kind of just do
everything that you need to develop it
strategy in this this I'd like I'm just
doing it all in one notebook makes it
easy so now that we have our signal the
S&P 500 the rolling three-month like
daily rainfall then we can start to use
alpha lens to actually analyze how that
signal does so here I'm putting the
signal through Apple n so there's this
there's this function here we highlight
it which is like formats or data and
then once it's formatted we pass this
factor data variable in to create
summary tear sheet and this will make an
alpha lens care sheet which allows us to
look at our signal and how in like what
our signal and like our signal is
correlated to prices or vice versa
so what alpha length does is separates
our data into quantiles so you can see
the 10th quantile here is like where
where it has brained the most so point
you can see the mean is point nine five
so the 10th quantile is stocks where it
has rained a lot and as you go up like
the first quantile is stocks where it
hasn't rained a lot day by day
and then you can see other things too
about that I mean this is just like a
summary tear sheet summary tear sheet
but alpha lens has like other things too
this is just a sort of a six inked
person of the full tear sheet and then
actually I'm gonna skip to the end first
again so here are ten quantiles again
and this is our mean stock returns for
each quantile so you can see in the
first quantile in the first quantile
where it hasn't rained a lot our mean
return is very high and in the 10th
quantile where it has rained a lot our
our returns are like negative so that
seems to suggest that companies where it
has rained a lot company's headquarters
where it is rained a lot will tend to
underperform and going back up so yeah
you can see like our mean returns aren't
all negative so basically this means
like if we invested with the higher
values in our signal we like if we went
long on the higher values in our signal
and short on the lower values we'd lose
money so maybe we we probably want to
reverse our signal and also this is just
using our test pricing data should have
mentioned that because we don't want to
expose ourselves to the dative we've
withheld and then this is our turnover
which is basically saying like how much
how much does your signal change day by
day okay so looking so from alpha lines
it seems like that it seems that our our
signal should be that stocks where it
rains a lot other headquarters we should
short and stocks where it hasn't rained
we should go on okay so now moving on to
actually like building it a trading
strategy with this information so if any
of you if any of you have used
contravene with
or this is like very similar to that so
this is using zip line which is what we
use at quanto peon this is our this is
our back tester basically and it's
pretty easy to run on your own
so this initialize function here this
just like sort of sets up variables for
us so you can see this short short
threshold here is means that any socks
where the rainfall signal is above 25
where it has rained a lot will go short
and then the long fish hold is any
stocks where it hasn't rained a lot with
signals less than 0.15 then will go long
and there's some other stuff I'm setting
up here like just shut the gross
leverage to one so we invest exactly we
invest around a hundred percent of our
money I'm just using a zero transaction
cost so no slippage in Commission so
this just allows us to get like a good
first look at the signal without having
to worry about this stuff like mudding
muddying the waters and then this
basically the schedule function thing
just means I'm going to run this trade
function which is defined down here once
at the start of every week so then this
trade function basically just grabs the
rainfall for the current day so I can
get the current the current day in the
back tester by using this function in
get day time that I imported up here
which pulls out the current date that
we're like on in the back tester so this
runs through every day and trade will go
once a week so like it this will return
like the week bid the date of the week
start every time you call it so then
every week we grab we grab the three
months signal of rainfall but just like
with using the the data on that day our
signal
and then we iterate through every stock
there and if the signal is above 0.85
then we go short if it's below 0.15 we
go long and that's all this is doing so
we just set up this variable Long's and
also shorts long stories the stocks
we're going to go long shorts as the
stocks we're going to go short and then
here's where we iterate through things
and just invest such that the total
exposure to the market
the total long exposure in the market is
50% of our portfolio and same with
shorts except on the negative side yep
exactly so that's what this thing here
is this closes the previous positions so
anything that has anything where the
signal has gone out of that that 15%
threshold on both sides which gets in
the middle then then we close out our
position okay so that's our training
strategy you can see it's like not too
long pretty simple so then this just
runs our strategy right no so we're just
closing it if the signal goes outside of
that 15 percent match but yeah you could
add to this like maybe a more developed
strategy would like put in some stop
loss like that yeah ok so then to run
this algorithm we just use zip lines
outrun algorithm and we run start
through end here we just pass in our
initialize function and 1e6 is a million
dollars that's starting capital and then
we also pass in the pricing data and
here I'm forward filling it because if
there's missing values then I find it
too simple most simple - for fill um
but you don't have to okay so now we
have we have the we've ran our algorithm
so this gets our the results here gets
stored in the results variable and so
you could look at this officially it's
bit more like a data frame of results
I'm not showing it here though I think
the best way to look at it is just using
PI folio so this is the this is the last
package in the sort of pond token open
source suite so I just pass the results
into this convenience function here that
will format this for us so just making
sure here that so actually I should say
I'm even running the fullback test on
the data we withheld just for the sake
of this presentation but if you were
actually developing this you would
probably just want to use the test
pricing data because but for this
presentation I only wanted to do I just
want to do one back just run didn't want
to deal with multiple so for this first
here treat though we're only looking at
the first two years results so this is
like just still with our test data
q well so I use this function called
create filter sheet with PI folia and
this just makes a bunch of plots for us
so the first thing that you'll see is
all these statistics that they algorithm
like annual return Sharpe ratio which is
like our risk adjusted return a bunch of
stuff our beta which is our correlation
to the market and this is good that it's
close to zero all you learn more about
that stuff on your own
so here's our cumulative returns so you
can see so the gray here is the the S&P
500 returns the s py and the green is
our strategy so as we can see our
strategy is up in to the right so that's
great and that's what we might predict
given the sort of a strong signal we saw
a novel ends where we had the consistent
we have the consistent returns
correlation with rainfall data so yeah
there's a there's a ton of box here we
have longer short during this time yeah
so there's other plus for that I'll get
to those yeah so there's a ton of stuff
here so just more forms of cumulative
returns here's our beta you can see it's
still close to zero which basically just
means is uncorrelated with the market a
rolling sharp so sharp is very noisy as
you can see like it's we have a shock of
four and then it goes all the way to
zero like you know these months later or
something
there's some a French which are another
type of exposure so we'd like you to be
low but these are fine clustered yeah
do you think that months later you're
just talking about to do some
seasonality yeah that could be yeah
definitely um like you're saying like
spring to fall like that yeah I guess
that would make sense no but yeah that'd
be good okay so these are just draw time
periods which is like how much we've
lost from the maximum amount of money
we've made more return stuff so I'll get
to our positions so this is so just a
list of our positions this all
auto-generated yep so you just call that
creates all tearsheet thing and it will
automatically generate it yep and here's
our exposure which is what you're asking
about
so we specified that we wanted to be 50%
long 50% short with
one point Oh gross leverage so we see
that that's the case
we're 50% long which is the green 50%
short and our net is right on zero which
helps us be uncorrelated with the market
so if I just go down here so this is our
total holding so like the number of
stocks we tailed so you can see like the
most amount we've held is like around
175 but we usually hold like 75 or so or
80 submit yeah there's probably some
seasonality here too I'm sure and this
is kind of expected so it's expected
that our total holdings goes up and down
significantly because we didn't specify
we just wanted like 10 names on the
short side 10 names on the long side we
just said like anything that's above 15%
on either so I just take that and here's
our long and short Holdings sort of
plotted together so you can see it's
like very spiky sometimes we only hold
like one short position which is
probably not good so if someone were to
like actually you know improve the
strategies maybe they would want to put
like a minimum of like five names on
either side or something to reduce your
exposure in one name our gross leverage
we can see is around one and it's not
perfectly I'm on enough because we only
traded once a week so if we if we trade
on Monday and then the market changes a
lot our returns change a lot during the
week then we don't adjust for that until
the next week but we're plotting daily
so that's why it's not pinpoint on one
daily turnover so this it's spiky here
obviously because we just traded once a
week but again we're calling daily daily
trading volume so for whatever reason we
treated a lot at the beat at the
beginning of 2015 or around there
and yeah so that was just using our are
sort of in sample data our test data so
now that we've theoretically like
developed our strategy although I'd like
gone through quickly then at the end of
this process then we would use our full
data set and so here I'm just passing
the same thing except I'm not using I'm
using the full results and I'm also
passing a live start date so this allows
us to break this this allows I going to
break up our results into like in-sample
and out-of-sample so we can confirm that
the out-of-sample looks good like given
what we've seen in sample so we want to
make sure these things are consistent so
yeah so you can see that like from these
stats our out-of-sample also looks good
which is great
our volatility is about the same our
Sharpe is actually a little higher
although again that's very noisy our
beta is still close to zero so here's a
plot so we we have this this green here
is exactly what we saw before the red is
what's new and then we plot this cone of
like expectation given our in sample
data it uses like some Bayesian stuff
uses like PI MC 3 my colleague Thomas
wiki has worked on that and we can see
that like given our cone of expectation
are our live results fall within that
cone which indicates that we haven't
over fit our algorithm which is very
easy to do so that's good so there's
some more stuff but so here I'm not
actually plotting the full tear sheet
you can see I'm just plotting like
create returns tear sheet which is sort
of just like the first the first section
of the photoshoot we were looking at
before ok yeah so it looks good it's
funny because when I like was trying to
think of a good example for the sauce
I didn't actually actually expect this
to be good but I guess it is okay yeah
so this is just the returns tearsheet so
you have some possible improvements for
this so as I talked about we could
increase the size in the history of the
universe so we're only using like two
and a half years of data here but you
could go back and do like a ten year
back test
I think the anyway NOAA has rainfall
data from like like 1900 so the limiting
factor here is going to be like how far
back you can get the S&P 500 data I
think and maybe the pricing data you
could take other weather data into
account temperature like snow you could
just tune things like maybe like maybe
you want to like as I talked about maybe
you want to put like a minimum of like
five positions on the short and long
side so that way you're not like your
whole portfolio or have your portfolio's
an n1 stock and also again this is like
zero slippage and commissions so it's
possible that once you apply the effects
of slippage and Commission that the
returns here go to zero and this is
really just like a fairly rudimentary
result you have to like take this in
develop it further to actually like
consider trading real money on it okay
so thanks everyone so that if you're
interested in the notebook that can be
found at the link here prism and um we
go
well that is all how to get you reserve
it oh oh sure okay yeah well there okay
yeah thanks everyone and let me know if
you have questions
so if you could speak up and also if you
could kindly repeat the question yeah
sure are there are there any
restrictions and I bring in 100
different teachers and throw in fancy
scikit-learn ensemble and then have zip
lines that test that for me or there's
certain restrictions about what yeah so
the question was about how complex an
algorithm could get in zip line so it's
really just limited by your computer I
think I haven't personally run into any
problems with it I assume if you have
like a huge server you could do
basically whatever you want yeah that
answer your question
okay I think you mentioned earlier in
earlier talk about a line to add like
tensorflow capability yeah right so you
can use center flow with this actually
it's just on the quanto peon platform
like quanto p.m. we don't have tensor
flow yet so that's one of the reasons
you might want to consider using open
source stuff because you can like it's
on your computer so you can do like
whatever you want with it yeah when you
showed your closing cost closing prices
like 500 oh yeah so that's because um so
that pricing data has pricing for all
the stocks that have ever been in the
S&P 500 yeah so that I didn't talk about
that but yeah so we we have three years
of S&P 500 data so there might be some
stocks that are in S&P 500 one year but
not in the next year so that way we have
sort of like a union of each year and
then so that's why our the pricing that
it has more than 500 columns yeah sure
so let's say like you create a rhythm
and you want it put it
how people usually actually yeah like
trade real money yeah and sorry that I
forgot to repeat the question but yeah
so the question was about like how you
can actually trade real money on
algorithms so if you use Cointreau pian
knots as a harp on that but you can do
this much more easily and but if you
don't want to that's fine I think there
is so you can connect things too like
Interactive Brokers pretty easily I
think there is a branch of zipline that
has actually like interactive broker
like integration I think it's called
like zipline lives if you google it and
then obviously you can just like output
the data from zipline so you could like
however you want you could just take
that data and like put it into like
whatever API you want we use black box
data work I don't know actually I don't
want to like I don't want to like say
anything that's wrong so there might be
a question for someone else
yeah so considering that it does so well
with a rainfall data
have you considered adding things like
sunshine the amount of humidity and yeah
I think that would be like the next step
anyone wants to try that out do you
think it would be as successful on
futures so considering I don't know is
really it like yeah maybe it would be
yeah I have no idea but maybe that that
you could definitely like test that
pretty easily because zipline also you
can use futures data you can just put
any like pricing data you want into it
so sure well wasn't the initial
hypothesis that productivity would be
higher during
heavy rainfall so the initial hypothesis
we'll go back yeah so I just said that
it would has an effect on the company
stock price because this paper said that
returns tend to go up like investors are
more you know they're happier when like
it's sunny outside it so maybe like when
they visit the headquarters then they're
like more you know they're happier about
that company so they think it will go up
and then this this paper actually also
says that so people are more productive
when it rains out but they're more
creative when it's sunny out yeah yeah
what's the most successful algorithm so
yeah weak point opium we actually repeat
the question so I keep forgetting I the
question was about what the most
successful algorithm that Kanto game was
ever has been so we actually like don't
look don't allow ourselves to look at
the code so that's part of our Terms on
the website it's part of our agreement
with authors so we don't actually know
what we don't know for sure what these
algorithms are doing because it's still
the the author's intellectual property
so I can't really answer that question
do you just buy this basically yep
sheriff you're measuring performances in
real performance like including
individuate for shorts and you know the
probability of taking yeah so not in
this not in this analysis um but you
could include that like this does yeah
yeah we're trading real money right now
so we just started trading real money a
few months ago actually so it's pretty
recent it's pretty new for us yeah
are you noticing people front running
your positions I can't really talk about
that any other questions just for my own
curiosity those on yeah I just read it
today no you're like algorithm how many
features on an approximation we've come
to the they're very emphatic how many
features yeah what is one yeah so it
could be any it could be one or it could
be 100 you know really any anything that
makes money you only need one good one
yeah exactly you just do one good line
yeah I have a static that's paying 9%
and one thing 11% so that'll be yeah his
name is Ellen if it was dr. bill after
this yeah yes so the question was where
our tools are yeah so they're all in
github it's it's a github comm / quanto
pin or you can just google like any of
these packages and I'm sure they'll show
up yep mm-hmm you concert anytime we
need autonomous all of you the info so
yeah so we're using the three months
rolling mean so there's there's sort of
a lag there and then also it's the
pricing data is like one day after that
yeah oops yes answer questions before we
wrap em oh I just had my own selfishness
I'm curious I hear a lot of great
questions how many people actually trade
or do some investing here and up that's
a very good about yeah so what's that
will close let's give a another writer
applause and thank you for a great job
we often please have time left over I
encourage everybody to stick around a
little bit longer to the network to
interact with each other and I feel free
to use this space for a little bit
longer thanks coming